hey I'm not very good at relationships
I've made a lot of mistakes when it
comes to men like for example for like
about two years I was in a relationship
with a married man I was married to him
was a mistake but it's true I was
married for a little while it didn't
work out nobody's fault
definitely not my fault actually like I
don't regret getting married but I do
regret who I married so like if you are
gonna get married just don't marry
Nathan Brown
from Portland Oregon that guy sucks but
I'm doing good I'm dating again of a
boyfriend he's yeah he's cool he rides a
motorcycle which is awesome because I'm
afraid of commitment so kind of works
out we do argue sometimes about little
things like I really like to watch
sports but he doesn't like to watch
sports he likes to watch soccer
I like to watch real football American
football
mostly because I like to play fantasy
football yeah is anybody else to play
fantasy football raise your hand yeah
keep them up let me see yeah who's one
of your guys Todd Gurley nice all right
for the rest of you fantasy football is
just when you fantasize about having sex
with football players
[Music]
[Applause]
great pick well I got to get out of here
but I'll leave you with some
relationship advice okay it's a it's all
about communication
in the bedroom okay you got to
communicate to your man what you want
what feels good
you got to coach him through it this is
what I do pay attention all right babe
pretend like your tongue is a basketball
Steph Curry's got the ball in the
backcourt dribbles it up to the top of
the key passed a dream on dream on clay
clay curry curry clay clay curry curry
clay clay curry curry clay play curry
curry clay don't worry about the shot
clock
way back to curry curry steps back
shoots a three swirls around the rim
wrong rim still swirling around the rim
[Music]
I don't know about you guys but I
finished so thank you so much
[Applause]